hey youtubers is Charlie so Steven Amell
dropped like the first teaser for their
big four night crossover and everybody
was freaking out earlier today so this
gonna be a breakdown there's a bunch of
stuff behind the scenes that's going on
so I'm just gonna explain what that was
all about and what's happening this week
big time tbh Justice League crossover I
loved Stephen amell's teaser here -
coming soon so most of you saw this and
like me you know kind of made the
Deadpool squee face like oh my god I
can't believe this is happening but then
your mind starts jumping through the
hoops and you're like it's way too early
in the year for them to be shooting the
big crossover episode the big four night
crossover episode so what's going on why
are they all sitting here this is a
current photo so what you're looking at
if you don't recognize all these boots
I'll start at the top and go around
clockwise so you have Adam up at the top
you have the flash Grant Gustin you have
white canary then you have Supergirl
with her apple red boots down here then
you have Steven Amell the person taking
this picture so the thought was really
early in the day they're like okay maybe
they're shooting like a promo a trailer
to show off because the crossover
episode is probably going to be Episode
eight of most of the shows so there's
just like a whole bunch of stuff that
they have to do before they start
shooting that episode like they haven't
even dropped the first trailer for
Supergirl season 2 yet but then it got
so much better Jared Padalecki posted
this picture of him and Jensen tearing
the sign off of Stephen amell's parking
spot and making like they're gonna take
a piss on it and they also quoted
something about doing photo shoots so
it's like okay very clearly all these CW
actors are doing promo shoots for the
next year so you'll probably see some
high-resolution pictures like you know
nice shiny really awesome looking
pictures of all the CW stars in the next
week or so Stephen Amell had the best
response ever just you know best thing
ever to happen in that parking spot all
in good fun in real life Stephen Amell
is super Bros with Jensen and Jared so
like they hang out in real life when
they're not filming their shows so they
just have a lot of fun with each other
but we actually did get some details
from Greg Berlanti
on the crossover he confirmed that it
would be like a singular threat that
would unite all shows he didn't say if
it's gonna be extraterrestrial like
something that we haven't ever seen
before something from the Supergirl
Superman comics like Darkseid Jack Kirby
fourth world if it be that big or if
it's gonna involve some plot with the
Legion of Doom but it's gonna start with
Supergirl on Monday night it'll start on
her show and she's going to be jumping
from show to show so there's going to be
some
Govan that's gonna help her travel the
multiverse to get to earth one to help
out arrow and flash and then presumably
on the last night the time travel show
legends of tomorrow that's when they'll
fix it so they're gonna have a whole lot
of fun with Oliver and Diggle meeting
Supergirl because they don't know who
she is they've never met a Kryptonian or
someone that can do what she can do
they've met Barry and he can do amazing
things but Supergirl is like an order of
magnitude greater than that so in all
likelihood what I'm expecting is is that
there'll be some new thing from the
Superman Supergirl comics that will pose
the big threat that will also involve
Legion of Doom in whatever their plan is
you know whether or not they're doing
Infinite Crisis or a crisis on Infinite
Earths it would be a pretty amazing
title to use but we don't really know if
the multiverse itself is gonna be
critical to whatever the villains plan
is so either way there's a whole bunch
of stuff going on but I know a lot of
you want to know if Supergirl they're
gonna like merge her earth with earth 1
so that she's on the same earth as Barry
and Cisco they will answer that during
this season of Supergirl like we have
Lex Corp and we have Cadmus labs so
there's any number of places they could
develop universe altering technology in
the vein of STAR Labs
so next order of business this week so
what's happening this week there's
actually some big stuff happening this
week that might explain why they're
doing all these pictures right now so
the TCAs are happening right now if you
don't know what those are it's when
television journalists go and listen to
networks hawk their wares so it's like
hey we have all these new shows coming
this is what's happening with these
series it's kind of like a comic-con
situation where they just do q and A's
but hopefully because it looks like they
might almost be done shooting with
Superman on Supergirl season 2 is they
might drop the first trailer with him
and drop some new trailers for arrow and
flash the Olympics are happening right
now so like there's a new Star Wars
trailer that's gonna drop this week
there's just like a whole bunch of
eyeballs on the internet and on TV this
week because of the Olympics so it makes
sense that they would try to drop some
more promos now there aren't a lot of
new characters besides like you know the
Wally West costume that they could show
off but a lot of people will probably be
asking about legends of tomorrow just to
society stuff they said that they've
completely changed that show so if you
weren't a big fan of Legends in season 1
season 2 is going to completely turn
that around
Supergirl season 2 is the same deal it's
gonna be completely different from
season 1 is that you're going to feel
like a real comic book show so get
hopefully they will drop trailers this
week you know of course whenever they
end up posting whatever they end up
talking about I'll do videos for but
their panel isn't happening till
Thursday so be sure to subscribe to get
that the DC giveaway still going on now
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video there's been a bunch of Suicide
Squad stuff happening just because they
just drop that movie is doing
gangbusters overseas they're probably
going to wait a while to announce what
the sequel is going to be but I've
already done a couple videos for Easter
eggs I've done my review I've done
videos for what I think they're going to
be doing next I'll post links in the
description for all that stuff but if
you guys do have any requests for the
new seasons of Supergirl legends of
tomorrow arrow flash anything like that
so leave them in the comments and get
hype for a giant four night crossover
because this gonna be like one of the
first times I think we've ever seen
something of this magnitude on TV while
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click here to learn more about
what's going on with Superman on
Supergirl season 2 and you can click
here for all my Suicide Squad Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight